bonsoir thierry lardeux noah merci
d'être avec nous alors finir l'hydro si
chloroquine en tant que traitement
potentiel décidément que deux
revirements sur cette molécule c'est une
surprise pour vous on imagine une
déception je suis pas forcément une
déception
moi je m'amuse un petit peu de sept de
ses scénarios
en fait il aura fallu quatre mois pour
se rendre compte que l'hydroxyde
chloroquine n'avait pas sa place au
stade hospitalier de la maladie les un
étudiant de troisième année de médecine
l'aurez aisément expliquer à tous ces
messieurs 2 ms et j'espère que on
envisagera à l'avenir que les étudiants
en médecine soit aussi bien payés que
ces messieurs pour produire les mêmes
résultats
donc vous franchement c'est pas une
innovation spectaculaire
ma deuxième question et de tir mais
pourquoi retirer de cette étude
l'hydroxyde chloroquine à ce stade si
effectivement elle ne fonctionne pas il
n'y a pas de problème particulier à la
maintenir chez les patients qui ont donc
eu jusqu'à présent l'hydroxyde
chloroquine sera classé cinquième parmi
les médicaments qui ont été essayés à ce
stade de la maladie encore une fois donc
ce stade un stade évolué de la maladie
qui n'est pas de toute façon sa place et
on saura qu effectivement l'identique
lors qu'il n'a pas de place au stade
ultime de la maladie et puis dernière
question qu'il paraît la plus
intéressante puisqu'on a un tel
empressement à retirer l'hydroxyde
chloroquine de ses études c'est que les
autres molécules ont obtenu des
résultats spectaculaires et j'attends
qu'on nous les produisent et qu'on nous
donne des résultats spectaculaires des
autres molécules ou qu'également on
retire de l'étude toutes les molécules
qui n'ont pas donné des résultats
meilleurs que l'hydroxyde chloroquine et
je pense que comme nous aurait dit notre
président jacques chirac
les études seront rapidement cheat ça
veut dire quoi thierry renard de noix
que vous pensez dans le fond qui a un
traitement particulier autour de cet aïd
roxy chloroquine se sait que ça a
suscité quelques passions effectivement
bégaie tueur bien sûr ça suscite des
passions est-ce que c'est assez
extraordinaire
depuis le début ceux qui sont les
tenants diderot xi chloroquine et encore
une fois je n'en fais pas plus partie
que ça nous disent c'est une molécule
qui est intéressante au stade initial de
la maladie la maladie à plusieurs stades
et là plusieurs phases et
à plusieurs moments on nous dit c'est
qu'une molécule signé intéressante au
stade initial de la maladie et depuis le
début on s'acharne à ne l'utilisé qu'au
stade ultime
évidemment on pouvait vous répondre
depuis le début qu'à ce stade là hydroxy
chloroquine n'a vécu pas eu de place où
une place à redéfinir d'une autre façon
alors aujourd'hui on nous dit des choses
que nous savons depuis le début c'est ça
qui est assez choquant à et depuis le
début on perd du temps à essayer des
molécules au bon stade de la maladie
pour guérir des gens et sauver des
milliers ti voilà le l'enjeu il est là
l'enjeu il est là oui ce qu'est ce qui
est quand même frappant quand on voit ça
un petit peu de l'extérieur sans est un
spécialiste c'est qu'il ya de nombreux
pays qui l'utilisent 7 chloroquine un
les etats-unis la russie
pourquoi elles sont en un problème aux
yeux de l'om est ce ça je ne suis pas
capable de répondre pour le ms moi
j'avoue j'avoue ma grande curiosité et
mon étonnement que l'on n'ait pas mis en
place une étude correct on l'avait je
l'avais moi même proposé de mettre une
étude correct en place pour vérifier si
oui ou non cette hydroxy chloroquine
avait une place dans le traitement du
corona 10 et du corner 19 au stade de
début de la maladie
on aurait déjà les réponses et on
saurait si on peut l'utiliser plus tard
parce que faut pas oublier quand même
une chose c'est qu'aujourd'hui on nous
dit a pas de solution on est en train de
nous faire des tonnes de peur et on est
en train de me dire la maladie revient
la maladie revient et on n'a toujours
pas de vaccin et on n'a toujours pas de
traitement moi je ne comprends pas
pourquoi
à ce stade on n'a pas voulu faire les
essais nécessaires pour identifier une
place de l'hydroxyde routine également
de la titre missiles éventuelle dans le
cadre de la maladie quand on écoute les
médecins de terrain on a pu constater
qu'il y existait une place pour ces
molécules
alors la définir avec précision utt le
pouvoir et le devoir des pouvoirs
publics qui se sont acharnés à faire
tout le contraire
je n'ai pas d'explication à ce problème
moi je fais des constatations le fait
qu'ils font sensation du moment qu est
ce qu a révélé selon vous thierry
lardinoit cette séquence
les sciences sont un petit peu
décrédibilisée ça a révélé aussi qu
avait énormément
on savait déjà des enjeux financiers
majeurs aussi hein parce que oui et puis
ça ça aussi révélé encore une fois le
spi talent au centrisme et le fait que
dans dans ce pays
alors qu'on a un tissu médical de très
très bonnes qualités de très haute
qualité
on n'a encore pas voulu aller se tourner
vers ce tissu médical et interroger les
médecins terrain de terrain dont je fais
partie et des dizaines de milliers
d'autres qui grâce aux si elles ont fait
leur travail et qui grâce au ciel en
sauver un bond à mon sens c'est à mon
avis des milliers voire des millions de
français en faisant leur travail
on n'a pas voulu les interrogé de savoir
comment il était possible d'envisager et
de prendre en charge une épidémie de
cette gravité et de cette soudaineté
voilà ce que ça met encore en évidence
on a voulu encore des ordres qui sont
descendus temps au et on n'a pas voulu
voir sur le terrain comment pratiquer
les médecins parce que les médecins ont
soigné les médecins ont soigné leurs
patients les médecins n'ont pas
abandonné leurs patients ils ont soigné
leurs patients et finalement la
catastrophe n'est pas aussi importante
qu'elle aurait pu l'être
vous êtes optimiste pour la suite
alors c'est qu'on s'est compliqué de
vous dire par nature je suis optimiste
je crois je crois en la science et je
crois en ma profession j'ai le sentiment
de ce que je vois que c'est épidémie
n'est plus aussi virulente et ne
reprendrait plus tôt pas la virulence de
l'avenir mais je ne lis pas dans le marc
de café donc pourtant pour autant
l'hypothèse d'une reprise épidémique
n'est pas complètement nul
donc il faut en tenir compte et encore
une fois en tenir compte c'est de faire
une veille observationnelles et c'est
d'ailleurs observationnelles ne peut
venir que du terrain elle ne peut venir
que des médecins généralistes qui dans
leurs cabinets ont des patients et qui
constatent des symptômes
nous avons constaté cet hiver des
symptômes atypique pendant tout l'hiver
personne n'est venu nous demander la
nature de ces symptômes
est ce qu'on pouvait faire vis-à-vis de
ces symptômes personne pour se rendre en
compte ensuite qu'il y avait une fameuse
épidémique corona dont peut-être nous
avons vu les premières marques dès le
mois de novembre
merci beaucoup en tout cas thierry
denoix d'avoir été avec nous je rappelle
que vous êtes médecin généraliste membre
coller du collectif kobe 19 laissons les
médecins prescrire merci à vous